many of these people were in kabul a
matter of hours ago now they're safe on
an airbase in germany under the
protection of the american military
twenty thousand evacuees have already
come through here
brought on giant transport planes
the accommodation is rudimentary but the
mood here is one of happiness and relief
each of these people has gone through a
traumatic journey
raffy says if he'd stayed in kabul he'd
be dead
definitely
they will they would kill us you know
i'm the person that uh
one of my family members worked with the
u.s embassy and uh they blame us that
why your family members is working with
the u.s military
among the crowds lima and her father
hamid at the start of the month she was
a news presenter on afghan television
now she's a refugee
too much
dangerous to live in afghanistan in that
situation with taliban so they didn't
allow girls to go to schools and
they're too much scary persons
hamid had founded the television network
it was staffed only by women 20-year
achievement just we lost it in less than
24 hours
and the new life with the new chapters
might be stopped but it's very difficult
but then we know we have a hope and we
have vision to come back stronger the
people arriving here are housed in this
sprawling tented village
medics told us that most arrivals were
in good health
but the work at this base is relentless
the general in charge talks of a heavy
burden on him and his staff and suggests
they don't always feel appreciated part
of the problem is the people's
understanding of what's going on in the
u.s is very different than the real
world that sounds like an element of
frustration on your mind
yeah i wouldn't say it's a frustration i
think it's a passion it's a passion
about taking care of people throw the
politics out of this this is humanity of
people want a better place you know and
we talk about giving them a better
opportunity
this is an american air base it's an
enormous logistical operation but it's
also about international collaboration
i've seen soldiers here yes from the us
but also from germany from france and
those wearing nato colors coming
together to help
these people take a first step towards a
new life
you do get smiles here and also optimism
these are afghan evacuees boarding a
flight to america
adam parsons sky news ramsey air base
western germany